School you've never been beat well yeah
man as I'm getting older and realizing
High School's uh freshman year Zoom by
so fast I don't know how fast college
and sat or act testings are coming up I
never thought of it much until my
parents Asian you know U it's a girl and
you were being very disrespectful oh
sorry sorry sorry sorry yeah I never
thought of it much until my parents told
me that my cousin got into Cornell God
damn Cornell University this is beyond
me this is beyond me bro yeah what how
you going to tell that the silver
spoon's over here I'm over here making
my sweet
bro I'm making my good juice dude we
need this motherfucker's advice bro like
what I'm write some [__] to you ask you
some questions dude what's your email 5
4 3
21 everybody
Welcome
eot where is it trying to
read well we have another episode the
genius brain podcast with the OG cast we
have Patrick T Riley currently not an
active stand up comic cuz there's no
standup comedy clubs open he practices
[__] with me though he says them to me
and I say yeah that's great and then we
have this guy it's me guys it's Nick
what it
is the cookie floor eating
[__] yeah this is where we put in the
the audience yeah yeah yeah everyone
starts
cheering cookies cookies so we got some
exciting [__] news and I'm just going
to announce it right now even though you
haven't agreed to it
apparently our good friend Chris Sosa
will be boxing this man in a ass
celebrity boxing match it's the coron
virus Invitational I can't believe you
two are going to box each other I'm so
excited yeah dude I'm uh I'm excited too
I just found out two days ago my buddy
Jose shout out to Jose Ray Jose R who's
uh the homie he would actually be great
on this too he's [__] crazy but funny
as [__] uh he has been dude this dude
okay so he grew up in watts and he has
his whole family from Hawaii here like
he has like he came over to my house
Hawaiian Mexicans I've never heard bro
he moved to Hawaii right yeah so he
started in Watts moved over to to Hawaii
when he was like 17 and uh started a
life there became a chef then found
standup comedy moved back to do comedy
or whatnot but he had a couple kids over
there so now he's been here for a while
since the quarantine he was hit up his
his baby mom was like Hey like send over
the kids you know so he has two
daughters they're over here he has a a
kid with another baby mama now so he has
three kids of his own he sounds like a
stand up guy but then then [__] like
all these all like his cousins like
everybody so he came over to my pad he
came with like 30 [__] kids he was
like for real yeah he came with his
whole family and [__] but they were all
cool as [__] but this dude's been boxing
cuz he's bored as [__] and uh he asked
his Jim like hey can we put on this
fight like I I know a bunch of comics
that'll fight each other he has like 16
fights lined up right now what the [__]
he has like 16 17 fights lined up comic
just a bunch of comics that he just hit
him up like hey are you down you guys
way about the same you down to box this
guy and he's like yeah and it's like
it's there's going to be some hilarious
fight some of the dudes where you're
like these dudes don't look athletic at
all but [__] it like this shit's going
to be dope you know that's awesome so so
out of the 16 fights how many people
actually box or like know how to box
well he said some of them I know did box
or have boxing experience other dud
Champs and [__] other dudes are just
Scrappy like they just look Scrappy as
[__] and other dudes just look like they
don't belong in there at all but like
[__] it let's just let's just make it
happen that's where it's fun dude but
it's going to be three thre minute
rounds and then he I guess me and Chris
weigh about the same I think Chris
weighs we're supposed to meet at 150 so
I around like 155 that's like what I'm
at that's why I was like why don't we
just box at 155 like about 150 dog at
has to be 15 like we're like let's and I
was like okay whatever like we can cut
or maybe I'll hit up Chris and be like
he you done to just boxing 155 like so
we don't have to cut weight you guys
might just lose weight from just the
training in general though yeah I'm just
going to put this out uh he's hyped yeah
hyp he's AP to box like he's we're going
to ins so Chris right now he doesn't
live in LA he moved back over to Houston
and so he's going to be training with
his dad oh [__] okay tight yeah damn
that's I didn't know he went back to
Houston yeah so he's back in Houston
because of the quarantine there's no
point in being in La there's nothing
going on here yeah so at this point in
his case I mean I guess long story short
for him he I mean he told us his story
but he got his uh car jack that broken
into damn absolutely terrible and so
basically what happened with that I'm
100% sure after he told me that story
the security people jacked his [__] yeah
there's no way his car could have been
stolen like that and they were acting
really aloof about it they jacked his
[__] car while he went away on a
weekend damn and so they're like I don't
know cuz he he Liv like he lives in an
apartment building and it's like a gated
parking garage yeah so it's like of
course with security cameras and the
security cameras happen to not work that
day what the [__] that's some Epstein
[__] that's the fene logic the same D
that sucks ass they sex with his car was
nuts they G everything and exhaust
yeah so I guess you're going to train me
dude you're my trainer guess uh so we'll
see if I win then obviously hire this
dude if I lose and get knocked out then
this dude's a [__] phone either way
don't hire me was it last time you had a
boxing match like an actual boxing match
I've only like just boxing I've only had
one boxing match like I did Muay Tha us
like that's what I started with so I
have I have the video it was a long time
ago let me see what year it was I was so
like janky about it though I was so get
like I everyone came with like their
nice boxing shoes I had basket like had
basketball shirts black basketball
shorts a black tank top so you couldn't
really see where my like my belt was so
we had we we Savant put like this white
tape around my waist like we just taped
white tape and it like tied it in a bow
yo who was this homeless man here dude
you fighting for a sandwich
bro years eight years ago years ago damn
yeah so yeah that was the last last time
I think I fought fought uh other than
that I mean just training and sparring
like with with like how we do it but um
it's going to be fun dude we start a
fight Camp baby baby I got to run dude
that's the thing I you can't run out in
this [__] weather I know that's the
problem see we got to go move to Houston
I got to run in place at home
just just a bunch of hies I got Chris's
picture on my window like Rocky
like got you some meat markets or some
[__] you got to punch you some me
are throwing in his eyes we got some
wood to chop we got to figure some stuff
out we got to get creative dude cuz it's
going to be Smoky for like a month so
they said October the world is on fire
California we are on fire right now
possibly like this building at in
recording this podcast could cat just
right outside this [__] window last
night you could see the whole Mountain
Side in Flames it looked like a scene
out of Lord of the Rings that's [__]
bananas and I didn't have my camera
either G I was so sad [__] idiot I
could have recorded
history and I didn't do it have you been
riding your bike absolutely not not in
this [__] you can't do anything I see
dudes jogging sometimes still and I'm
like they don't give a [__] about their
lungs they going lung cancer dude losers
I walked to my car and I my lungs hurt
and [__] you know what I mean there was
a lady jogging the other day too I'm
like what why what is this what there's
Ash in your eyeballs right now cuz I I
biked around a little bit just around
the neighborhood once and then my
[__] eyes were on fire dude just from
the ash alone yeah no it's [__]
terrible bro it's like M it's like you
trained somebody this morning didn't you
it was in their house it was inside of
their house but it was really close to
the fire cuz he lives like further down
further east so the fire's like out the
window yeah like bro this dude this dude
took a picture of like where he was last
night and it was literally it looked
like he could reach out and touch the
fire that's how close it was because
it's the mountain side is right there
it's right there it's right there bro
what the [__] is going on like this year
I mean I know it's cliche to be like
2020 what but like God damn bro like
it's literally [__] like like we have a
moment to breathe for a second we're
like all right we're going to get
through this and then just [__] cuz
cuz [__] with Corona virus the one
thing we could do is go outside exercise
get some physical activity but now at
least in California even Northern
California Northern California's [__]
too like they can't do [__] it's weird
because it's tragedy after tragedy and
it makes you forget about the previous
one there's so much like I I I'm not
worried about coronavirus anymore as
we're talking about it right now I just
remembered about a huge explosion in
Lebanon I don't know what the hell
people go through in Lebanon but when
the explosion happens there's no screams
it just goes boom and they go all right
and they just move on they wake up they
dust [__] did they see if you just go
through a bunch of clips of people doing
whatever they're doing during the
explosion nobody screams yeah it just
happens well my buddy he's Lebanese like
a a good friend of mine and he's gone
there his whole life and he was like
yeah that's standard like he was like
yeah well that level
he's how I wake up he's like that's that
one's a little bad he's like bro like
there's bombs that go off all the he's
like that's just that just happens like
we live in Els Serino and there's always
like fireworks and [__] and he's like oh
this is this this is like this is
nothing this is normal like but like
it's way louder over there cuz actual
[__] bomb going on but he's like it's
fine video dud shakes it shakes it
shakes there's a dude in a car and he's
looking at the Smoke Stack or whatever
he's recording it it explodes the shock
wave shatters all of his windows in his
car not phased at all
he's driving all the window shatter and
it's just he's still holding his phone
and
just with he's with his family he's like
yo that was a big one huh guys let's
goit let's get out of here so I'm trying
to figure out what's going on over there
that that nobody gets scared by that
[__] are we just soft is that what it is
I I think especially California we're
probably soft bro like I mean we don't
got to worry about nothing like that
ever definitely not [__] bombs yeah
dude that [__] happens all the time over
there according to them I was talking
about this on the other podcast that the
fire started because of a gender reveal
thing and then now there's this whole
new conversation about kind of obviously
like the stupidity of what a gender
reveal party is right and then on top of
that there's another conversation
beneath that because it's a social
justice issue because of there's they're
saying that there's not there's no such
thing as genders because of the whole
non-binary thing so you shouldn't do
that because it excludes the 0.2% of
people that are non-binary we got we got
to stop all this man we got to stop all
this the do it I'm do it this is what
we're going to do right when you said
that I pictured this Spotlight and your
cape came out of your [__] back this
is what we're going to do we're going to
take all these cookies we're going to
drop them on the floor and we're just
going to eat them until we figure out an
idea of how to stop all this that's my
number
one that's how I solve problems
chocolate chip chocolate macadamia and
just people people were pretty [__]
upset about people still having gender
reveal parties not even about the fire
the fact that half a California is
burning it's because of the whole that's
what's crazy is that like literally my
[__] your house is on fire and
you're still like but what the [__] two
gender like bro damn like time in place
dude yeah we got to get rid of them
dude whoa hey Hitler over here what you
say get the social justice Warriors that
want to talk [__] about all this stuff
sounds like you said get rid of
transexuals what that's what I
interpreted cuz they don't do as much
they don't do anything compared to
social justice Warrior so what do they
do in the first place is what you're
saying hey do they just live their life
and they do what they do and that's all
I'll say about it no no no what is the
do that they do I don't know they have
they have jobs they live normal lives
just like everybody else right what's
normal there's no what is what is the
definition of normal I can't please
everybody man this is hard what's the
definition of normal explain [__] Cy
White
yeah it's a social construct normal is a
social construct of society I don't know
dude I don't know where I'm going with
this yeah what don't you know Nick damn
that gender reveals are [__] stupid
whoa can we cut those out what are you
talking about the clip or
just the whole clip of you burning right
now no no of all gender reveals can we
just all get rid of gend are
representative of the fires of the
mountain you are just burning down to a
nothing absolutely 26 Acres 26 hund
thousand thousand acres that sounds
about right that's how much I'm trying
to figure out what the argument is and
once again forgive me I I haven't really
looked into this obviously because it's
not something that I'm aware of but
they're saying that there's there's no
such thing as two genders why so I think
the issue is so there's gender and sex
right so gender like I think I I'm not
sure if this is exactly how it goes down
I or something pretty huge dick baby I
see it's
true how'd you do that man the
flexibility everyone home that's
watching do this along with us let me
tell you something about gender
boy that's when he's about to talk about
something serious like hold on guys hold
on guys I got you so thing about gender
is and he just goes on so I think what
it like gender like the social construct
aspect of it is like what we culturally
Define as like a male thing like uh
being aggressive you know versus a
female thing which is being uh caring
you know and in that sense it's like
yeah there's a spectrum because like
there's some feminist dudes and there's
some really masculine girls and and I
mean probably more times than not dudes
are more aggressive because of
testosterone and hormones and all that
[__] and I think sex is when it comes
down to like XY chromosomes like dick
and balls or a vagina so so are this guy
dick balls vagina I mean [__]
guys so and I don't honestly know what
the issue is exactly so are they upset
so so they're upset because it's called
a gender reveal party and not a sex
reveal party because if you call it a
sex reveal party it sounds like a good
time yeah they should just be like does
this baby have a dick or not and then
that's it just hot dog or taco what is
it
do that's what you Reve you pull the the
the the [__] little drape down it's
just a fat dick like like
Oh I like that dick see that's the new
gender reveal part is that way people
don't have to blow anything up I don't
know why people use pyrot Technics and
things like that cuz I believe that's
what happened you know you know how the
reason why the gender reveal party was
created it was actually they can trace
it back to a very specific person so it
was a lady
well there was two stories that I read
and I think this one is the real one the
first one that I read was that it was
because she had a few miscarriages or
whatever and before they could find out
the sex of the baby the the baby was
never born right I don't think that
one's the real one I think that's
something that somebody made up what I
read on a very credible Source Wikipedia
which I heard is a credible Source now
yeah it is it yeah I heard you could use
it on on papers that you write with
pencil like
references APA and MLA formats College
heads I guess she was upset because in
her family her one of her siblings had a
nephew and all the family was super
excited that the nephew was born and so
they put all their love and excitement
into that kid and so when she was going
to have a kid the parents basically
didn't give a [__] anymore and they're
like a it's another [__] baby who the
[__] cares huh so Italian so an Italian
family who the [__] cares about this
little [__] Gaba goul G little Gaba
goog little slant ey [__] it's a white
family but she got really upset not not
I'm putting words into her mouth but she
was you know she goes okay well I want
to celebrate this now so she decided to
do a gender reveal party and then from
then on it blew up but she's upset now
because now she wants the gender reveal
parties to stop because she thinks it's
dumb now yeah so even the the Creator
thinks it's stupid yeah cuz cuz at the
end of the day it's like yeah you're
having a gender reveal party which is
great but it's also like did you do a
genda reveal part who cares no no not at
all I mean well it wasn't we weren't
like in a happy
situation they they had a they they had
aive agressive real it wasn't it wasn't
like uh birthdays and cakes and [__] you
know uh but no the reveal was I was like
is it a boy or a girl and she was like
girl and I was like it's been
revealed to me everybody he just had one
brown balloon and it says it is done it
has been done the baby is here it is it
is completed bro yeah so um but it's
just a little
like it's just [__] annoying dude you
know it's like it's like some Mimosa
brunch like like it's in the same family
as that like not saying that you can't
do that and having a good time or
whatever but like it's just [__] like
man it just seems like it's only for
social media [__] up you know that's the
argument behind it it's it's what's the
purpose of it is it because you're
really happy about the kid or is it
because it's something really cool to do
do and you could put it for the gr I
just don't want to spend money let's
just let's just celebrate the baby when
it gets here because that's all that
matters the baby the
bab and healthy right that's what
matters CU there's a lot of people that
can't even have [__] babies you know
and they spend a lot of money trying to
make babies and stuff like that so if
what matters if you have a kid are you
going to whoop the kid's ass I I've
talked about this with Tiff I think I
don't know I don't know cuz that's how I
was raised I was raised by getting my
ass beat a lot and I think I needed that
by by ass beating I mean like spanking
not
not beat ass on the face yeah talking
about My Father Here Right top of the
head yeah every by the way every parent
that I know that says that they're not
going to spank their kids spanks their
kids really I think you have to I think
like they they verbally have told me
they looked into the windows of my soul
before when their wife was pregnant and
said I can never hit my child yeah
they're 2 years old now they be getting
ass whoop like a [__] spin kicks
the chest handing these ass whooping out
I think you have to establish that to
kid very early like if you act a certain
way you're going to get punched in the
face cuz that's how the real world is
right well there's just there's ways I
mean look everyone parents the way I'm
not again like I've never hit Maya I I
I've never even like really come close
because like I when I see her I'm like I
can't even imagine hit like if it would
feel like even when I get mad or like
try to discipline her I feel bad doing
it you know so I can't even imagine like
smacking her or or spanking her even
though like sometimes it feels like it's
well Des
uh because I would I would just be
[__] devastated to be honest that's
just me I mean I understand there's
certain situations if your kid has a
knife and he's charging you like all
right dude it's time for a knee to the
chest got soft on us bro like I mean
there's certain situations like like
where it's like okay like that dude
deserved a drop kick to the chest but I
mean everyone does things the way they
want to [__] do it
but uh yeah bro I don't know I I I don't
I don't think I could hit my what if you
had a son I'll beat that ass huh his
[__] ass ddts all day and his
name is Chris
Sosa three three minute rounds let's
go three piece in a Pedialite
dude drink it drink it little [__]
rehydrate electroly dehydrator watch out
electroly grape flavor you drink it um I
don't I don't know bro I I I just
personally I don't think I don't know I
would I would feel so bad know I'm not
trying to like like he kids
up for sure 100% I was thinking the
other day I feel like are like man [__]
you
then cuz I got I got a we got a new
puppy right the puppy's like six seven
months old now and I remember when we
had this puppy like i' I've definitely
whooped the ass of my dogs right and
with this dog I I watched a lot of uh
dog training videos just to see if I
could do something different because mil
this is dog number s and I'm like okay
let's just see this time I won't spank
this dog I I'll do what the white people
say on the video where you where you
talk to them you give them incense or
whatever and [__] right so Sage I get
the demons out and I thought I wasn't
going to spank this dog but I tell you
something I [__] whooped that dog's
ass once and I'll tell you that it
straightened the [__] up super fast it
didn't it I'm not saying that my
children are dogs but I'm say I'm saying
a little ass work today too one of theg
is is right
there one of the dogs to has a habit of
running out the [__] door every time
that the door is open and it's it's the
sister of the other dog and um not my
dog but it's Mariel's best friend's dog
and I was babysitting it today and she
was said I had to whoop her ass today
because she kept running out and I was
like oh can I whoop the dog's ass if it
doesn't and she goes she goes you should
I was like cool so I saw the dog just
ready to gun I grabbed her and I went
blip real fast that dog ran stayed 10t
from the door and said and bowed to me
like a [__] good Asian dog so s they
know bro they know dogs know that dog
had a [__] dagger to his stomach
about to do [__]
SE my mistake Lo behold doesn't even go
near the door now see wow yeah I mean
dude it does like I remember when I was
younger I had a cat and the cat shat in
the living room right and I was probably
like fourth grade I was like 9 10 and I
like was like no like her we just called
her mama kitty cuz we couldn't think of
a name we're like Mama Kitty we're like
[__] no like and I like kind of like
grabbed her I was like don't do that
like ah right like I like was like mad
at her and she kind of looked at me like
all right [__] idiot whatever and
then my mom comes out of nowhere right
and my mom grabs her by the [__] like
the Scruff of her neck shoves her face
in the [__] like this and starts
smacking her ass like you [__] b
b b the cat's
like cat ran sprinted out I'm watching
it like oh my God like I thought I
disciplined her like I thought I did it
something he did my job yeah mom beat
her ass and she never shat in the in the
house skin you know that's crazy usually
that doesn't work for animals
I didn't know you do that with cats dude
that Mama Kitty never shot in the house
again wow she traumatized never shat
ever it
dieded 5 minutes later it died got
really
fat smell like [__] all the time Mama
Kitty just take a crap
no TR dude bro Mama Kitty was so dope
though she was a gangster she used to
follow me to write Aid and [__] it was
sick as [__] but dude one time she did
yeah she used to like when I would walk
like a couple blocks ago to redid she'd
wait outside the door for me and like
I'd walk back she was like my bodyguard
and [__] like at at Red at Red she would
wait like Pace by the automatic doors by
the automatic doors and then I would
walk out yeah she was dope crazy and one
time she got hit by a car but this is
this I never trusted my uncle for this
because it was like Mama was outside my
uncle comes back and he's like Mom I
just saw Mama and kitty get hit by a car
and he brought he brought her in and he
said some other car hit her but I was
kind of like at the time I was like all
right let's just fix up mama kitty my
mom gave her [__] NyQuil and [__] cuz
like my mom was like what does Nyquil
have to do do with broken
bones ethnic family family medal purpos
that's my mom dude anytime I got a
sprained ankle I [__] uh jamed my
fingers [__] up my knee she goes
here's thlu what the [__] does thlu have
to do with my [__] up Ankle right
right dude I would when I was in Mexico
I remember I had I had a stomach and my
grandmother comes with me with a spoon
with dark syrup she's like here drink
this drink this I drink it it's
Coca-Cola I'm like I'm like first of all
Coca-Cola is not going to do [__] for my
stomach also why the why the spoon give
me why I like the presentation better
though huh I mean she was like the
bubbles she was like the bubbles yeah
give me the bottle though sence can or
whatever dude the bubbles fix
everything transfer it's a transfer the
bubbles
activation all right whatever but uh
yeah dude so I don't know but yeah [__]
your kids up you know what I mean yeah
well I feel like nowadays like I feel
like five years ago spanking your kids
was not as frowned upon as it is today
did you say so you say five years ago
yeah dude I feel like five years ago
everybody was like yeah I'll be my kid
everybody now though I'm saying this as
a fact everybody saying they don't whoop
their kids they whoop their kids maybe
not you you might you might be a little
different right well she's also not old
enough yet well I like I just um I don't
know for me it just it just hasn't been
the thing but like I have seen videos
like I remember there was like a Dr Phil
[__] where this like like kids going
crazy and this boy was probably like
eight to 10 and him and his mom are
talking he reaches up and he slaps her
in the face oh yeah so like okay if I
saw that would funniest thing I've ever
seen in my life she go he was trying to
correct her behavior by saying how do
you like it if I interrupt you when you
speak and he [__] slapped the [__] out
of his mouth and she was like oh yeah
that's all she she how do you like it
how does it make you
feel just like that see okay now that's
one of those situations where like all
right you've already [__] [__] up as a
parent in the foundation of of creating
this kid cuz like he got there for a
reason cuz you let him slide on too many
you didn't get in there verbally like
you already missed the checks and
balances that you should have taken
right uh to to let this problem progress
to what it was so now that you're here
now you're at the nuclear phase now
you're at the phase where it's like all
right this dude's only going to
understand
hands we're Beyond talk we beyond
talking but that's the parents fault
again because like you should have been
from [__] the the
like like if you if you're on it I think
from a young age like I said unless a
parent like a kid's rushing you with a
[__] bat or like something like that
like you shouldn't really I don't think
have to beat the [__] out of your kid
those are the one of those kids that you
got to send them to not Naked and Afraid
What's that show yeah Naked and Afraid
[__] it's not Naked and Afraid what
is that show the one with is it scared
of the dark scared put him in prison
something what is it called in prison
Scared Straight Scared Straight that's
what it is I like put him in prison
prison put him in prison I really suck
at show names that's why none of my show
ideas have ever gotten picked up I got
this really great idea where you put
kids in prison it's called put them in
prison put them in prison like wow never
have thought about that that's they open
the door they go hey get the [__] out
there go inside but scared straight is
the show that he should be on 100% yeah
yeah I feel like Scared Straight works
though it works I feel like it it works
it has to work when um if you let the
prison mates put their hands on the kids
a little bit dog just a little it's not
even that it's just their presence did
you see the episode with that dude named
dragon and it was a Mexican guy I've
only watch a I've only watched Clips I
remember watch he was like in prison for
like quadruple thousand homicide I think
he killed somebody found their spirit
and killed their Spirit again he did
some crazy [__] but this kid was
claiming to be a part of a set that is
opposite of his gang right and he goes
you know we don't and this dude dragon
by the way is [__] giant he's like
maybe 6'4 gigantic dude and he's like in
Chains like on his ankles and his wrist
for someck he's super dangerous I'm not
sure they did that to ham it up a little
bit but he's so scared because he didn't
even scream he just was whispering the
whole time he was like so where you from
he goes I'm from this set he goes you
know we don't like you there right you
come in here you're my
[__] because he would whisper it was so
[__] scary scary I think in that
episode the older brother who was
supposed to set an example for the
younger one because the older brother
was influencing the younger brother to
do bad [__] the older brother actually
changed but because the older brother
changed into a good person the younger
brother became a bigger Thug cuz he
thought his older brother was a [__]
now oh wow damn [__] nuts dude that's
insane that kids got to get beat up they
would do some [__] though some of those
pars would come out they would say the
most ridiculous stuff and I for for sure
they wrote those lines before they came
out like come out here hold my
mustache and then has to hold like the
tip of his mustache the whole time BR
there's always holding my poet my pocket
bro there's a '90s episode where some
dude's holding his pocket and the other
the other inmates are like yeah that's
his [__] that's his [__] yeah I get to
[__] you that's what that means I [__]
you yeah hold my pocket [__] my pocket
that's [__] hilarious man that's so
crazy I think watching that show is the
reason why I realized I can never go to
prison for anything I can't do it I get
eat alive I'll be holding someone's
pocket as soon as I walk in pocket I
hold anyone's pocket please he just goes
in he was like where's the pockets at
I'll hold anybody's pocket what's wrong
with you I only have two hands you know
when you said when you said you going
get eaten alive I thought you were going
to say someone's going to eat your ass
well that's what I meant probably or
eating my ass immediately yeah you're
just going to go into prison backwards
with your ass first I'm ready boys [__]
me right now cuz I feel imagine all the
guys in jail are like 65 and above you
know dude one of our uh business
partners you know you know him Jeremy
yeah so you know Jeremy went to prison
right when you when you told me this
after I met Jeremy for the first time I
was like you're [__] high off your
ass yeah Jeremy is like the most he
seems like the nicest dude ever but he's
also the most professional man I've ever
met in my life Jeremy is the sweetest
Soul ever I saw him once raise his hand
like this and seven butterflies landed
on him yeah that's it just like that but
uh Jeremy he actually went to prison uh
I think he told a story on Bart's
podcast but he went to prison for um I
want to say home invasion or some [__]
like that and this is back in the day so
he's actually Joe's old friend from way
back when so they used to do dumb [__]
but uh that's so crazy now now they're
business partners and [__] and Jeremy's
really cool because like his story is is
nuts because that's actually something
that happened to him that was a turning
point for him so Jeremy went to prison
and when he went to prison he found out
real fast that when you go to jail and
you're an Asian person or just anybody
in general I guess but specifically for
Asians you need to find the Asian crowd
if if not you're the immediate [__] and
you're going to get punked throughout
the whole [__] damn so basically you got
to pick your poison so even when you get
into the Asian set apparently what
happens is that you you're either going
to be the Asian people's [__] or you're
going to be just [__] up in the yard
just by random people you don't know
what the [__] going to happen to you
you might get raped they might just [__]
you up for no reason they might I don't
know kiss you in the mouth and you just
got to take it but I'll choose that one
I'll take that one but long story short
with his stuff they while he was in that
little small little Asian clicker gang
they were they were basically grooming
him to basically fight another young
inmate in there so for a few months they
were training him to fight [__] him
up jumping him or whatever and then like
the the day before he was supposed to
fight he actually got out early wow so
they're making push-ups they were
[__] him up and all this other stuff
yeah cuz if you would have fought and
got caught that's the shitty thing you
fight in there that's extra time yeah
you know you [__] up in there that's
more time what damn that sucks dude
that's crazy as [__] yeah and then after
that he turned around his life and he I
don't I think he went to I forgot what
college he went to but it's one of the
really smarts ones you know smart you
know like the college that I went to n
he I think he went ivy league didn't he
probably I believe it the way he talks
so you're telling me prison is not like
the longest yard at all you ever
absolutely not long as Y is hilarious
the way they portray that you know it's
like looks like a fun time play football
a really great time there a lot of
characters in there yeah the equipment's
not that cool but they still get what's
your what's your prison name uh and cing
Nick the ear this podcast is brought to
you by Amazon Alexa my friends I am all
about convenience I am all about making
my life easier well guess what genius
brain listeners Amazon Alexa has a smart
lighting bundle for you if you guys have
not hooked up your home with smart
lighting you are missing out and I had
no idea how easy it was for me to set up
a light system where all I have to say
is Alexa turn on the lights and boom I
don't have to flick a switch I don't
have to go anywhere the moment I step in
the house all I have to do is use my
words and God said let there be light
with an Amazon smart lighting bundle you
can turn your home into a smart home in
just minutes setup is easy and you don't
need any extra equipment just connect
your new smart bulb to the echo Dot and
you're all set you can also set lighting
routines to gently wake you up in the
morning help you wind down at night or
completely turn off at a certain time
right now you can get 20% off your
Amazon smart lighting bundle only at
amazon.com/mytv
[Music]
I it probably be that I'll go with that
with a K though hey silver spoon or
something I'll be like yeah that' be my
prison voice just super high pitch why
you [__]
flamboy like the the [__] bandana in
the front and [__] like the Tupac band
yeah yeah but I'll be yeah yeah yeah is
that flamboyant if I do that with that
voice hey lotus flower yeah yeah what's
up sugar that was that that pretty good
right no you're serving sweet tea to
people now that's all I make I make the
best toilet sweet tea and everybody
likes me because of that way you know
what I mean cuz it's all about the brand
it's the product and everybody will like
it how much how much are you charging
for it though um a Lucy just one Lucy
that's it o yeah I'll I'll be I'll
charge for one for one 32 ounce is going
to be one cigarette and that way I could
use that to barter for other things cuz
that's the currency like what um sh like
shivs cuz you got to protect the
business you know what I mean you got to
protect you got to protect my my my
recipes that's true
the intellectual property baby that's
right like where do I get LLC like we
don't got those in prison sugar I why he
talk he didn't talk like this when he
first came to prison man prison change
Nick prison change Nick cold
blooded he keep stirring up that tea
with that shivy traded for that
Lucy with his [__] toothpast tooth
toothbrush [__] [__] he turns his SMS
I know I know you also some of this good
juice don't
you oh you call it good juice and I just
wear apron with no shirt on I been like
Hey Y'all what's up you know they got
cookbooks of [__] uh prison recipes
crazy where you could where you could
replicate these prison meals the homie
we used to train with would tell us
stories about like just him in prison
right and he would tell us like if he
would mix a certain amount of like hot
Cheetos with like called spread with
with with Top Ramen he'd be like bro it
tastes just like like chili cheese fries
I'm like what the [__] and they would
find ways to make like whatever food
that they have in the the commissary
whatever they could buy to replicate
what they have out yeah exactly like
this one tastes like orange chicken I
swear to God bro you got to try it I was
like dude that's [__] crazy that's
insane but is dope though don't make
that [__] on YouTube and they eat that
[__] like it's the his name buff black
dude his name call muscle he would make
J we got to [__]
now that's the ladies
baby
but that dude would do like all these
really crazy like prison like meals hot
protein for for for maximum muscle
hilarious because this fool would say
this [__] with such conviction on his
YouTube channel he go I never took
steroids in my life I'm like Cali muscle
let's be real here guy stop it he said
he would only eat ramen and and he's
still this buff I'm like come on guys
like stop it dude let's not do that
let's look at the science here yeah
what's what does the science say that
he's on steroids there it is well guys
we're gonna get into the genius advice
of the day oh I'm not gonna say
anybody's name once again name say their
name okay this this person is David
so all right like I have been listening
to your podcast and I love the advice
laughter and mindfulness from it I am 15
living in California and Asian-American
as well what's up ching chong ching
chong I grew up very I don't know why I
did that oh people didn't take that
sound bite and ruin me I grew up very
well going to private Middle School
tight i' appreciate and then trans and
then transitioning to a public high
school that's rough uh I have oh what's
up offer up somebody wants to buy my
[__] sorry
ignore I have loving parents and a big
brother well now you're just showing off
huh dude we
get you have
money and you have to go to public
school you've never been beat well yeah
yeah as I'm getting older and realizing
High School's uh freshman year Zoom by
so fast I don't know how fast collagen
sat or act testings are coming up I
never thought of it much until my
parents asan you know U it's a girl and
you were being very disrespectful to oh
sorry sorry sorry sorry yeah I never
thought of it much until my parents told
me that my cousin got into Cornell
godamn Cornell University this is beyond
me this is beyond me bro yeah what how
you going to tell that the silver spoon
over here I'm over here making my sweet
tea bro I'm looking my good juice dude
we need this [__] advice bro
like f I'm going write some [__] to you
ask you some questions dude what's your
email you can only give advice as silver
spoon I'm sorry just put some lemon in
it
baby let me show youall how to build a b
from the ground up from a toilet up my
brother is also an alumni of UC Irvine
wow you have an amazing pedigree dude I
love it I love it I'm not making fun of
you that's [__] dope uh I immediately
balled into tears after hearing the news
of my cousin because I feel so scared of
my future what why wait what hold on a
second I never thought of it much until
my parents told me that my cousin got
into Cornell University okay we we'll
explore um bald in tears because I feel
so scared for my future my parents never
enforce strict rules onto my grades but
of course they want uh me to get all A's
this wasn't the drive of me getting good
grades nor wanting to get into top
colleges it has always been myself
enforcing that type of high standard
which I also don't get why I do so you
know why cuz you a winner baby you
[__] winner you're bred for this yeah
don't apologize for being a winner and
having good habits listen to Silver
Spoons come on baby Sil spoons add some
lemon in it um recently I caught up with
an old friend that I met on an uh met
abroad uh summer Exchange program in
guanga this is so dope you live the life
man yeah this D like7 bro your life is
awesome I'm so jealous [__] five [__]
in the process of writing this
message uh we were talking about our
future uh our career plans or any career
plans uh of that matter we just
concluded the three words you know I
don't know family members of peers uh
asking about my future just scares me
and I have built up so much stress I
just cry it out I know every teen has
been uh there qu has been there
questioning themselves at this point I
want to become a nurse to have a stable
job and for my parents not to be totally
disappointed in me o I got some advice
for you [__] for real I know my parents
would support me in any shape or form
but I know in the back of their minds
they will be thinking of the worst so my
question is what kind of advice for any
teen struggling with what they want to
do in the future any personal
experiences when you were a teen and
then we'll address the other two three
or four number one you're a [__]
teenager quit stressing the [__] out
yeah you you literally were just a sperm
not that [__] long ago right right a
blink of an eye yeah you know I'll say
this though like there are certain
people that I know in high school that
were very fortunate to figure out what
they wanted to do from the onset of
their birth uh I have a friend really
close friend of mine shout out to my to
my hom girl Phoebe so Phoebe she knew
she wanted to be a lawyer since day one
she was in like mock trial and
everything which she somehow convinced
me to do which by the way I was the best
and you just call everyone a stupid
[__] you're a stupid [__] Cas close
David wins another one prosecution says
you're a dumb seaword get the [__] out
of here I was the best I dressed up in a
suit and I came every day with a pretzel
in my mouth and I said you know what I'm
taking a bite out of
crime it was amazing actually I was just
a character witness that I had to play
and I was a dumb farmer
and that is a fact that give us a taste
of like what do you mean yeah a dum like
I was like what would you say so what
did you what did you so they were like
oh so what did you see that n well I'll
tell you
what when you when you wake up in the
morning and the de is hit in the grass
you can't really see much because you're
relishing in God's creations they're
like actually we cannot use any of this
testim hold on let me tell you this
right now so when Jesus Christ came down
and he told me look at the D on the
grass I touched the dud put it on my
finger and I said magnifying glass that
right there is God's
creation so was was the title actually
dumb farmer yeah it could have been it
really could have been it may or may not
have yeah or it could have just been
regular farmer and I just became the
dumb farmer and they got really upset
that I played that character that way
we're like we're in California be a
California did you see the murder or not
well let me tell you something about
God's
creation stand for the next 5 hours
can't get it out of here just say what
you need to say let me introduce you to
my wife uh silver SPO
I'm like hey y'all just make sure when
you making this sweet tea you don't put
too much
[Laughter]
ice oh [__] Silver Spoons silver
pver I like
that I [__] play on words it's a
double on baby [__] that's in a Disney
movie so right now if I were to say this
you're kind of basing what you see from
like the ideal situation right where you
meet somebody who's a teenager that
knows exactly what they want and a lot
of the times when when people your age
say that they know what they want is
only because they haven't really
explored other options right you see a
lot of people when they go to college
the first year of your college isn't
really there for you to set your future
it's really for you to figure out if
this is the career the path that you
want to go into a lot of people that I
know they started off as a business
major econ major whatever and then the
second and third year they switched it
up and they became happy with their
future careers later on as of right now
if you think that your goal is for you
to go to college that's all you need to
focus on get to college get to the
college that you want and and be happy
with that choice if making your parents
happy which by the way we'll address
that later on is something that's a part
of your goals because you want to have
uh that's important to you then get to a
good college and figure that out or go
to a community college for a couple of
years and figure it out then definitely
you know there's nothing wrong with that
like you put so much [__] stress on
you I and I I think it's like an Asian
thing or something I think it too dude
hey man wao dude you can't say that no
it's true though because when you're a
teenager you think there's so many
there's only so many things that really
matter to you and one of those things
that really matters to you was like
where am I going to go to school what am
I going to do for the rest of my life
like cuz that's what everyone else that
you think has it together at your age is
already thinking I'm still figuring it
out dude yeah you know like we have we
have a really good friend that she went
to P she was going to be a physician's
assistant and that's a pretty great
living and she left that to come pursue
a job in like the podcast world you know
what I mean so it's like she was going
she was almost going to be a physics
assistant she went through years of
school and it's not easy either she
could have done it she could have
finished really quickly but she uh
decided to make the jump and she's so
much happier now than when she was being
a physician's assistant so it's like
that happens all the time and the one
thing you said about like oh I want to
be a nurse I I'll be a nurse just so I
can make a good living it's like
don't that type of job I would say don't
be a nurse unless you really want to
help people and you really want to
provide care but the reason for you to
want to become a nurse is really dumb
and that's the worst thing ever well the
reason why I say that is because you're
basing your goals off of somebody else's
dreams which is the dumbest thing ever
right and I say that because this is
this is advice that my mom gave me right
and so when I was when I was in college
number one the worst college student
ever I'm over here stabbing people like
like multiple time different different
stories of stabbing people and I'm a in
college like you like I went to college
because uh number one it was something
that I I was told that I needed right
that I had to do this I obviously wasn't
very good at the books learnings right
it wasn't that great
um at all and so yeah I will wak I will
wakes up and look at God's
creation there not go Toge back at it
again B are you playing that character
or is that just you now are you having
an aneurism okay why do you always have
a [__] piece of wheat in your mouth
and a straw
hat but harmonica so my mom told me too
she goes and though this was a
conversation that we had about choosing
the woman in my life this can be applied
for anything right she goes at the end
of the day how you live and the stuff
that you do you have to live with your
own choices that's what it is your
father me your brother we all might pass
away uh before you do so you have to
live with those choices the person that
you marry the person that you're with in
at the end of the day it's all your
choice you have to be able to live with
those choices I could tell you right now
that this is what's going to make you
happy but you know you you know you
better than I do right so if I so if we
could put it into how my mom was telling
me this advice about women that I'm
going to be with she goes yeah I would
love for you to be with a Korean woman I
would love for you to be with a woman
who's who's Christian has all these
values that I really enjoy that I think
is important but when I'm gone you're
going to be married with her you're
going to have kids with her and that's
the person that you're going to stay
with for the rest of your life mean if
if you're with this woman because you
wanted to make me happy well what
happens when I die right you know you're
still left with that choice that you
made based off what I wanted and not
what you wanted and that goes for the
same thing with your career yeah you
know yeah that's great advice um yeah I
think uh also too for this kid like he
is putting I don't know if it's a is it
he or she it's a she okay so I don't
know if it's a what did I say this kid
right you said he you said she no you're
good oh I'm good I'm good okay um
there's no gender no gender there no
gender Ral there was no gender Ral so we
don't know [__] thinks transgenders
don't do anything at home yeah this guy
right here [__] silver spoon over I
say that Jesus dude so sick of you dude
but what I didn't that I think too like
with people like kids just like you're
15 like just be a [__] kid too you
know like enjoy yourself as well like I
it's natural to be like what the [__] am
I going to do in the future because
there's all this stress imposed by you
by society and other people but I think
even like with college like now in
retrospect one of the coolest things
about it wasn't just the education that
I got but like just the experience of
being away from home and like kind of
having to being out of my comfort zone
really and like figuring out how to like
establish new relationships and like
start from the ground up be the new guy
whatever blah blah so it's not just all
career career career career um but you
have to take into account like those
other factors that are super important
for your life too that will help you in
your career when in whatever you choose
anyways yeah and if you don't know a
specific goal like you you don't know
what you want to be let's just say you
you don't know that you want to be a
doctor or a lawyer or you want to go
into Finance or whatever right then then
let's go a notch down say I want to get
into a really good college because I
want to have a great education well cool
if you know that's a definite in your
life then you know the steps that you
have to take in order to get there right
right so don't don't worry about that
just just start with there first find a
find a tertiary goal that will help you
get to that later on but because that
that specific goal won't matter unless
you get this done first anyways so so do
that take those baby stapes and move on
stapes hang out me too
much stes like the thing for me too is
like when I was in college I hated it I
was like dude I was majoring exercise
science and that's not even real this
just said this one just said I study PE
no dude it's a real thing it's like
science and like physiology red rubber
balls that was my science and we did we
did like whistleblowing we did a bunch
of stuff like we did all these DRS yeah
yeah I'm a fat olist all right that's
what I am what the [__] yeah I was
studing exercise science and I was like
you know what got all loud got all
loud
science we started making sweet tea
funny is the dou is
real no like anyway so uh [__] you guys
uh I had a minor in playground go
ahead I had minor in monkey bars watch
your [__] mouth
wow dude we learned the appropriate like
slides to go down like kind of a cool
thing how do you hand how do you handle
the swirly one you know we stayed away
from that that's on my Master's
Degree I wasn't ready for that that was
actually the study I was going to do it
that's heavy uh centrifical force
and
centipedes human centipedes human
centipedes human centipedes
that's what I wish I stud brother but
while while I was in school I I dreaded
it I hated it I did not like it I
thought going to college was a waste of
time because in my head I was like you
know what I'm going to be a fight coach
like I'm going to be teaching people how
to kickbox I'm going to train Fighters
like in my head I was so set that's what
I was going to be doing right and a lot
of the courses I took to were also
nonsense especially like the science
classes and stuff like that I didn't
like it but um when I graduated and once
I started working with like teaching
kickboxing and doing like following the
career that I wanted to pursue I
realized that man I'm so glad I went to
school for what I did and I I was really
happy that I studied all that stuff
because later in my life I decided to
kind of go down that route and kind of
double down on that so it's like in your
head you might think this is my only
path this is what I'm going to do for
the rest of my life but it's going to
Pivot you know it's like you don't know
what where you're really going to settle
on what you want to do in in your life
so it's it's very fluid at least for me
so yeah and I and I think too there's
too much emphasis on people thinking
about regrets right they think that you
waste time you don't really waste time
with life experiences because that stuff
does help you in the future yeah AB
that's what I was worried about I was
worried about like making the mistake of
me going down a road that I thought was
going to make me unhappy and I wasn't
going to want to do that so I I was was
like you know what I'm G to do what I
like to do and that's the only thing
I'll do from there and that's what my
mind was set but in reality I was just
putting myself in a box and I kind of I
didn't pay for it but it just you paid
for it with your tuition yeah yeah
exactly kind of you know but let's go to
their number two I'm glad
okay shut up you stupid [__] I like you
when you when you uh what was my name
again H Silver Spoon like Sil spon
Silver Spoon
Bon that's right that's the restaurant
name that's a new Splash Mountain right
at Disneyland baby Silver's poon come on
dog taking sweet te into that yeah so
what are your thoughts on the Asian
stereotype of having Straight A's uh a
4.0 GPA and always having to be on the
top of their classes do you think it's
fair for other Asians that aren't the
brightest academically you just call
people dumb that's tight uh I think that
expectation isn't just for Asian people
I think it's anybody who's just going to
Academia I think you're putting yourself
in that box right now you're putting
that Asian stereotype on you right and I
don't know if it's quote unquote an
Asian stereotype but it's it's not
really a stereotype it's
facts you know your parents want you to
get good grades because when they were
told I'm not sure what generation your
parents are but my parents had this idea
that when you come into this country
it's here for opportunity and because we
came here and we sacrificed to make sure
that you have this opportunity I want
you to have good grades it's not just a
stereotype of oh all Asian people are
smart you need to good have good grades
it's because of the burden that your
parents had to come here in order for
you to achieve what you what they
thought would be a great life for you so
let's just go ahead and reframe that in
general I I don't like that I don't like
it when people say like oh is it unfair
for your um Asian people to have to be
really smart we are [__] smart why is
that a negative stereotype but it's not
just that it's just like yeah they're
smart but it's also they put in the work
and that's what it is they decide to put
their work in to their school and it
shows that's all it is I just never
understood that stereotype of being
something negative right well it's like
it's like it's like when you were when
you were in school cuz nobody called me
smart I was so pissed well and also too
like you're not going to be like this is
unfair for people that aren't living up
or whatever but like it's like that's on
that's on how the [__] is what's
positive going to be you know what I
mean like it's on you for being dumb
yeah it's on you [__] it's really like
when you were in school did you feel
like you work that hard at school a lot
of the times like generally speaking
like high school yeah when I was in high
school I didn't like as I was nearing
the end of my college like um career
what the [__] career as I was nearing
the end of college IED was Sciences
exercise sciences and I was like this
monkey bar class is my favorite and I
was really into it but like when decided
like look I like this class I'm going to
work hard at this class you know
cleaning slides and cleaning rubber
balls I decided that like you know what
I'm going to excel at this I'm going to
I'm going to I'm going to put my time
and effort into this and by the way too
I don't think it's it's just an Asian
thing in your case for thank you for
giving the background for where you come
from Academia is something that's in
your family right so they have
expectations of you being getting the
four-o in the great GPA because you have
relatives that went to Cornell that that
was an alumni from UCI
so expectations are also because in your
family you guys have really smart people
so you know it's it's hard right because
parents just want you to to excel right
and if they if they think in their mind
that that a really good education is a
way for you to have Financial Freedom so
why wouldn't they expect that from you
of course there's nothing wrong with
that right not at all you just have to
learn how to compart compartmentalize
what that does to you right exactly
right no 100% you got to that's that's
yeah that's the perfect way to say it
you got to learn how to take it and use
the momentum of it but also so not be 15
and crying every night typically you
know what I mean so much pressure to be
smart it's like yeah but you're going to
feel that pressure anyways right you're
going to when you have a family you're
going to feel the pressure of being a
good mom when you when you I don't know
when your kids grow up and maybe they'll
be a sh a little [__] then you'll feel
the pressure of your kids being a little
[__] no matter what stage in your life
people are going to have expectations
for you no matter what if you don't feel
that pressure and like being good at
something that you care about then
you're not a human being it's you feel
pressure when you do stand up like [__]
I got to get these jokes out I got to
make sure I'm funny I have to deliver a
certain product what I do yeah 100% And
bombing sucks ass exactly oh god dude
bombing feels terrible I bomb all the
time dude it's fine I still sometimes
I'll be driving or in the shower and I
think about a time where I bombed and
I'll just be
like no I scream no I
no why did I say that no I tell me the
worst time you've ever bombed on stage
[__] dude the wor the worst I got got
planties I got I got a bunch of bombing
stories dude especially in the beginning
oh my God bro I have um before you do
that let's get you a little
alcohol D I mean I had I I had I mean
I've did I did a retirement home one
time like an old folks home oh why would
you do and well dude I was year one like
year one
and it's stage time like it's all about
stage time stage time stage time and
actually the guy that's organizing the
fight uh
[__] got got me in he's like hey
bro let's do a [__] I got a show for
us like it's at a retirement home it it
was at 3:00 p.m. daylight right oh my
God daytime no microphone big ass room
not not like a old folks home with like
healthy old folks it's like old like
convalescent like they're on their way
out like we got some problems in here
you know and and uh like the first the
front row like people are looking like
left and right like I I remember I told
a joke without a microphone
[__] couldn't hear [__] told
the joke look to my right the guy in the
front row was just passed out like this
he was just like oh my god dude and I
was like so
anyways I kept going I and a year one
you don't have any jokes anyways it's
just stupid ass [__] [__] there's
no there's nothing I don't even remember
dude but I remember at exercise science
this this guy [__] old guy wheeled
past me he was like cuz it's so quiet
you
hear he Wheels in front of me and I just
stopped talking I just watched
him and he went over to this window he
just looked out of the window it was
like a wall too it was like a brick wall
there was nothing and he just put his
hand on his face like this and he
went oh my God it's so quiet you could
hear somebody exhale I was
like and then what made it worse is
there was some nurses there like the the
the people that obviously take care of
these old folks and they were just
looking at me like like if it would have
just been old folks that didn't know
anything I would have felt a little
better cuz I was like that's like I was
just speaking into a vacuum but there
was actually some coherent people there
that witnessed this and saw this and I
sat in the back and they would everyone
once in a while look over that's the
thing about bombing too is afterwards no
one wants to like if you make eye
contact with someone they like say you
bombed they look at you and they're just
like they like no one no one wants to
even look at you they know you have Co
no one wants to talk to you or look at
you like you'll walk by somebody and
they'll just be like yeah so anyway so
[__] know like it's like you're a
disease bro and you know what the thing
is too the shame dude if anybody starts
doing standup out there man H you have
to understand that the venue matters a
lot it matters about Vibe sound matters
a lot uh the crowd matters a lot and
drinks matter a lot so when uh I did
this one event for this one Filipino
dude named David shout outs to you you
[__] uh he he used to throw these these
these random events right and so when he
told me it was like oh it was a standup
event I was like oh cool it's going to
be set up when I got there it's at a bar
nobody really knows that there's
supposed to be a standup event going
down there's no chairs faced towards you
people were just eating all the TVs are
on yeah the worst the [__] worst and
a game is on oh yeah oh no like shut the
[__] up we're trying to watch the by the
way I invite all my friends to come too
beautiful and they haven't seen me do
stand up ever a few of them I was like
cool I got this set ready go this is a
Sacramento I go up and I look at the
venue and my ass starts to sweat I'm
like I am going to bomb there's no way
I'm going to be successful and so I went
up there and people can't hear me cuz
the TV is [__] loud they think I'm
annoying because a game is on that
they're [__] watching right now
minutes did you have to do I think it it
was a million that's what it felt like
it felt like a [__] eternity I go up
there I'm making these jokes I bomb I
just cut my set short I'm like [__] it
hey so nobody's listening uh [__] it and
I just and I went and sat down and so a
buddy of mine bet way better stand up
comic me at the time I hope he's still
doing stand up because he was really
good his name was Mike so white Mike
goes up White Mike so white Mike goes up
and he's he's irritated too at the venue
and that's actually his best friend that
set up that venue he goes up and then he
just starts roasting people in the crowd
right I like billway that's what I
should have done and then he you know he
made me feel good cuz he was like
defending me saying you guy is [__]
funny you guys are a bunch of [__]
[__] and then everybody turns around
he starts roasting people in the crowd
he saves the show I was like that's what
a comic is right there like you put him
in any type of situation and they'll
kill it but at that time that was my
second year doing standup it's all about
yeah no it's it's experience bro like
that those situations like I was the
same way and like hostile rooms or rooms
where people don't give a [__] in the
beginning I literally used to be so
afraid of just forgetting my jokes I
would just read them over and over just
to memorize I sounded like a goddamn
robot up there there was like no
Humanity in there whatsoever but the
more you do it you're like oh [__] like
especially those room you have to go
after them like one time I I don't
really smoke weed because I get paranoid
and [__] but this guy every bad
situation I've ever been in is involved
Jose so this dude
Jose Jose was like hey bro like let's
smoke weed like he this dude is like a
mega stone he's like let's smoke weed
you know and I like go on stage youve
never been high on stage trust me you'll
learn some [__] and I'm always like get
the [__] out of here bro like you just
want to watch me bomb like I know what
it is like you just want to laugh and
watch me bomb go [__] your you set me up
[__] but one day I was like [__] it
like whatever like I'm a smoke weed like
I feel I'm feeling you know rambunctious
I'm feeling adventurous so I I smoke I
take a couple hits of this joint and
like I pass it to him and I go to the
bathroom and by the time I close the
door and look in the mirror I'm already
high as [__] like faded as [__] dude and
it's like if you've ever been on Supreme
Scream like you know there's a point
where you're in Supreme Scream where
you're like all right this is really
high and I'm scared a lot and this is a
lot and then you look up and it's still
you have like 100 feet more to go and
you're like holy [__] so that's how I
felt I was like I'm already I'm scared I
don't even want to I just want to close
my eyes and just wait for this to go
away but I'm like I'm still going up I I
literally was having that thought and I
felt and I was I caught myself
rearranging shampoo bottles in the
bathroom like I was literally just
rearranging soap and [__] somebody's in
there what the [__] are you doing get
out of here I got to take a [__] the
lotion and the and the hand soap I don't
know which one goes first literally
malfunctioning dude like a bad Westworld
[__] robot like I'm just like like
her dad when he has the glitch or
whatever so then [__] we go to this
show in uh it was by Magic Mountain I
forgot Valencia or some some [__] some
show bar show we walk in there a few of
the comics are late the guy hits me up
and he's like hey by the way like three
of the comics didn't show up so I'm
going to throw you up first
I'm going do like I'm going to do 20
minutes up front because no one's here
and I have to the show has to start and
we're going to like it's going to go
you're you're up as soon as you get here
you're going up and I'm like I'm just
anxiety bro like just terrified I'm
getting nervous right now as you're
talking about I want to get out of here
also we're in this car we go on my so
it's Jo me Jose and this dude Wes who's
cool as [__] not a comic but he just
comes and he like films and he's just
cool as [__] and we're in West's car and
West has this beater like kind of [__]
up like old school BMW like just [__]
up the windows don't work
raping I'm you [__] and I'm like
if feels like we're going going to go do
a driveby like that's the the the the
vibe I'm like I need some hauling oats
right now like I'm so high I need like
something to calm me the [__] down kill
[__] left and right
[__] and I'm like just like
where like how did I get to this point
in my life is what I'm thinking we walk
into this
bar big ass bar big
Brewery no one is [__] listening to the
comic like and it is it is bro I'm
telling you loud like that that D
that loud they didn't have a drink limit
huh uh well it it was just like it was
it was just a bar show so it wasn't like
some people just showed was a bar it was
the same [__] it was a show that
happened to be at a bar yes exactly so
it wasn't like some people just were
like all I'm going to go get some drinks
after work and for some reason there's a
a guy talking and they're like well [__]
this guy I want put a [__] baseball
game on the TVs and you're there you're
right where I was dude yeah so they're
like let let me this dude just wants to
spit game at Becky or whatever and and
like he doesn't give a [__] about this
dude so he's he this dude's like no
one's listening except like three nice
people in the front row and I'm like oh
my God like I have to go on next I
literally thought about leaving I was
like I'll just quit comedy today like I
was like I'll leave I'll get an Uber
I'll never talk to these guys again I'm
like [__] it like I'm out like [__] this
[__] bro I'm to Mexico right now I'll
start a new life I'll leave [__] and I'm
sitting there like like cuz I knew like
in that situation like I'd done it for
long enough to to know that like I have
to attack these people like you have to
go after them not like per you just have
to get them going you have to get them
looking at you and then you hit him with
the material so I'm like sitting there
so scared like I couldn't even get up to
get water dude because I was like I
might look we like weird going to get
water and that was just too much for me
to handle like so just that interaction
was too much this guy go and then I just
hear all right come to the stage Patrick
Riley and I'm like ah so somehow I make
myself my way to the stage get up there
loud and I'm high so I'm like more
sensitive and I'm like hi guys and I
just told the truth I was like guys I'm
high as [__] and I'm so scared right now
guys like this is like my nightmare like
this you're this is it like I'm I'm
experiencing my nightmare right now and
some people kind of were like what and
like kind of chuckled a little bit and
then I I I literally felt like a ghost
like a ghost in a movie that's like
trying to get people's attention like
knocking on the window they're like I'm
here I'm here and everyone's like what
the [__] like what the [__] was that
knock and uh I keep going and I
thankfully somebody heckled me this dude
heckled me yelled something he had like
a really gay voice but his face like
didn't match his his voice and I just
asked him honestly cuz I was high I was
like damn is that really your voice like
I I didn't even wasn't even trying to
roast him but I was like Curious like
for reals and everyone laughed at him
right like they laughed at him and it's
cool you can see people's body language
up there he just like shrunk like this
he was like and uh everyone cuz I I I I
guess I shout I was asking a genuine
question
but everyone interpreted as like I
[__] them up they like oh [__] and
they all like paid attention to me like
they it got quiet in there and I was
like holy [__] I'm [__] doing it I
felt like I was in a movie like this is
crazy and they all looked at me and I
was like sick time to go into material
and then I was like what the [__] is my
material like I could not remember my
jokes at all bro and and you got through
you a bone I was
like [__] and I was like all right I
guess go back to crowd work cuz now it's
been 15 seconds of me just being quiet
and this is [__] weird so I just kept
talking to people and there were some
teachers in the front row and I like was
like what do you do she's like social
studies and one said she was a PE
teacher and I was like oh that's funny
cuz like you don't look like a lesbian
and and to me I thought that was funny
but to them it was like
a that's a funny joke that's a funny
joke you know where that would have
killed though that would have killed in
New York yeah cuz they don't give a [__]
like they they roast the [__] out of
they say crazy [__] that's a mild joke
joke in New York yeah that's why I
didn't think it was anything but they
didn't take it right and it just right
there it just all started falling
apart a funny joke falling apart some
other dude heckled me and then I tried
to like rebuttal but it got too like
it's weird when you respond to a Heckler
if you're too confrontational it just
gets awkward it gets like like are these
guys going to fight what did you say or
I don't remember I just [__] you up you
piece of [__] you [__] I'll kill
you I'll bur down your house [__] he
just goes boo you go I will [__] you up
in the parking lot right now I will kill
you in front of your daughter like who D
I know where your daughter lives and I'm
going to marry her who I'm going to
marry her and love her unconditionally
um yeah dude I don't remember but it
just got weird and then I bailed I was
like I I was high and then it all came
back to me and I was like what else
would you do at that I can't handle this
and I was like I'm out and the guy that
the guy that booked me was like I got
five you know like you got five more
minutes and I was like nah I don't I was
like I'm going to get off the stage I
was like I don't know what's going to
happen with the show but I'm leaving
right now and I just put the mic and I
got off and that was it that's that's
that's [__] frightening dude yeah the
only one time that I bombed but I got
saved luckily was actually because of a
of a person in the crowd I did a crowd
where it was all black knight and it was
just me and then accidentally I said the
N word oh [__] and it slipped because I
was so comfortable because I was doing
so well right oh no and I was doing so
well and it slipped and people were like
oh I got save somebody in the crowd
because when I said I went blah blah
blah blah blah and for the sake of the
podcast I was like I was like you know I
mean like that and everybody went whoa
they started booing right and this one
light-skinned dude was like it's like
he's like you can't say [__] like that
right but this other dude in the crowd
that was black he was like he go like
[__] you barely black
yourself and that guy roasted him and it
saved me CU I just latched on top of
that and I was like yeah [__]
the lightest [__] I've ever seen
I was like [__] I was like if
you tape your eyes back you can do me
and I started roasting this dude that
guy saved my [__] ass save me he was
a com thank god dude thank God for that
guy that I forgot I [__] forgot his
name but he saved my ass say what a
great
comeback yeah he saved my [__] ass
but he was a comic there and he was like
a veteran comic W so he was helping you
out because he knew I was killing the
crowd and it that [__] slipped out real
fast and it was cool because I had
background story because I grew up in a
black Bey supply store so I was talking
about all this the [__] so I had a great
crowd work at that point but that guy
saved my ass so I like I wish I
remembered his name but he was an older
comic but he roasted that guy for me BR
So Dope hilar so dope with that guy he
could have let you just die he could
have let me die cuz you would have died
I would have died when I when that
happened too I remember the the chill
that came from the top of my head all
the way to the tip of my like as soon as
it left I bet you just felt like oh [__]
dude like thinking about it I I
literally I'll be like I'll be like oh
it's just like oh that could have been
my could have been my Kramer moment my
would have been done damn it's so yeah
but that guy he dble he doubled down
though what's his name for sure Kramer
what's his real name Michael Richards
Michael Michael Richards his name is
Kramer from here on PL name let's go to
let's go to number three um I want to go
into a top college but I doubt myself
all the time I'm pretty sure I'm
definitely not the only one but do you
think this is another aspect of Our
Generation being careless of Our
Generations uh mental health you your
Generation generation actually cares
more about your mental health than mine
does remember when somebody told me that
they were dealing with depression I
called them a loser [__] Los I didn't
know what mental health was until like I
was like 25 my dog died I'm sad you're a
[__]
loser get over you little [__]
[__] so I talked I I really don't think
that your generation has an issue of
mental health because those two words
put together mental health wasn't even
in my vocabulary at your age so I think
it's cool that you are thinking about
your mental health but you're really
thinking about what's going to make you
happy and I'm telling you right now stop
thinking about that [__] so much because
you're not going to know right and you
have to understand that you have to be
comfortable with not knowing all these
answers life is never about definit
there's the only thing that you're
guaranteed in life is death that's it
everything else is a crap shoot and
taxes br oh it depends yeah that's true
right you could just always run away get
off the [__] grid that's true Wesley
snip did it you could go live in the
Wesley Snipes did it he know he went to
Joe oh yeah he did yeah yeah he couldn't
escape it with yeah but you know he
actually thought he was blade for real
yeah he's blade
they're going to find out where that
[__] is but honestly like at
this point in time I feel like kids
don't do this enough at this age they
don't think about experimenting like
this is when you have to start hanging
like you have to start trying to make
out boys or what are you trying to do
you have to start doing your mollies you
have to do your perco setes you do all
these things okay this is going to this
is going to shape your your your
adulthood okay let's ignore that no no
not drugs but like with with things that
you if if you're interested in in being
a nurse you should go volunteer at a
hospital things like that that's what I
did and as soon as I did that I was like
I'm not going to do Healthcare this is
terrible he actually killed somebody
accidentally nuts was nuts I was just
discharging patience and I all of a
sudden just down the stairs you're
healed that'll be $200 pleas $200 he's
right here give give it to me in P said
don't forget your sweet to te honey and
don't forget your sweet tee
baby da Dukes I mean doubt is just
normal
D it sucks it's uncomfortable you know
what will help you out honestly young
lady per going sorry is the same lady
yeah same girl she has a few questions
ask to do with this very detail go go go
fine go Train sign up for a for a boxing
kickboxing class or Jiu-Jitsu class and
[__] get it out over there and get
socked in the face and then it'll change
your perspective about [__] that you
don't have to worry about so seriously
cuz yeah that's that's what I love about
like training well when before the
pandemic when I was training at Strikers
like there would be some girls that for
real dude there would be some girls
there that would like they like if you
just saw him on the street you'd be like
this is the nerdiest girl I've ever seen
in my life and then you would start
seeing them kickboxing You' be like this
girl will [__] somebody up dude for
reals 100% like and and it gives them a
confidence and it's just cool like I
nerds are dope dude I like nerds I like
some skills man like go out and SK baby
skills and anything just find something
you like to do D you know what I mean is
that is that bad advice no that's good
advice some sweet tea get off your ass
number four your ass lastly do you think
it is better to follow your parents
wishes knowing they want you to live
happily and get into something you don't
uh particularly like quote unquote
nursing or go into something you
genuinely love but not be as successful
and have to work your way up dance and
singing first of all you just talking
[__] about me right
now well who say I'm not who says you're
not going to be successful in that [__]
you don't know that stuff you're going
to have to try it out and and either way
you have to work hard like if you're
going to be a nurse you still have to
work hard you have to work [__]
really hard and you might as well work
really hard and invest your time in
something that you actually love because
at the end of the day whether you love
it or not it's always going to be work
like I love what I do for a living I
love coaching people I love Fitness I
love all that [__] but there's going to
be point in times where I don't want to
[__] talk about Fitness I don't want
to do none of that [__] and I don't even
want to touch it but that's when it
becomes work but either way I'm thankful
that I love it because that's what keeps
me going back yeah you definitely have
to do stuff that you love but there's so
many I mean this is this this topic
alone this question alone can go into
like a whole another hour podcast but I
will say this though there's a couple of
things that can do right [__] this guy
yeah we both did this number one it's
you can go into a passion 100% and
knowing that it's a very precarious life
choice and then if you want to risk it
um but you're happy knowing that you'll
do it then go ahead and do it make love
to these two guys and then when you're
when you're an adult when you're an
adult and uh number two married man what
you can do is something that my friends
do right I know a lot of friends who do
this who they have a job that they know
that they're really good at that pays
well but they actually have their
passions that they're completely fine
fulfilling on their weekends y they go
this job is secure I need to be secure I
like the financial aspect of this and I
never want to give this up but it
doesn't fulfill this part so on the
weekends I'm doing my photography
business so there are options there's no
direct answer for this but if you're
trying to fulfill your happiness by
doing something that somebody else tells
you to do you are going to be unhappy
eventually and what I say eventually is
that I I am now at an age I'm 32 where I
know other people right now that are
like yo I just they just woke up from
this [__] nightmare that they had
because they thought that they were
happy or they convinced themselves that
they were happy and they go oh [__]
David I wanted to do a podcast like you
and I'm like hey guy you're not funny
it's not going to happen but what you
can do is stop having a midlife crisis
freaking the [__] out take a step back
and figure out what you want to do right
for real and especially nowadays this is
the time for side businesses like I feel
like with the internet and how like you
could structure your own business like
you could do literally [__] yeah he's
over here selling sweet tea out of a
[__] toilet B saying dude I S out the
trunk of my Miata baby there is
sweet tea wouldn't fit in that Miata
dude hey watch your [__] mouth bro
yeah no no no no no no no no Miata Miata
whoever's watching that own Mias or
Miata Fanboys just [__] start
commenting below about what a piece of
[__] this guy is no they're going to
also comment about how they still
haven't lost their virginity so hey join
the club guys it's not even you know
it's not that big it's bro you know your
virginity is so overrated dude it is it
is it really is hold on to that [__] for
the rest of your life yeah just keep it
keep it tight to you sex means nothing
when I first had sex let me tell you
something terrible you're like
I because I sucked you're like I wish I
didn't do this I assume that if you just
put it in everybody's having a good time
yeah yeah nope there's a lot more to it
guys oh it's so annoying Patrick knows
DM Patrick for your sex tips guys he's
really good nah I'm terrible bro I Su
Patrick just lays down and they just go
on him like a
pogo like thank you they have to figured
out their own angle yeah yeah I found it
BR Honestly though when you first
started having sex like how bad like
you're really bad God damn you want to
talk about anxiety that gives you
anxiety like thinking about like how
you're do again it's embarrassing oh
what still yeah huh wait
what wait wait wait when you get married
it's all good right you figure it out
yeah I I hope so I don't know what's
going on cuz I'm going to get married in
a couple weeks I just realized this girl
is 15 so let's uh let's yeah yeah sorry
we're not talking about that we're not
talking about for some reason I thought
you were I thought you were in college
so you were an adult apiz that's not
that's not what Nick wait why is it why
is
it cancel Nick Nick is the leader of
this [__] what # cancel Nick he's sweet
tea there's nothing to cancel Sil silon
baby we're going to make you a silver
spoon silon I want Silver Spoon shirt
silver spoon by the way she said we
could say her name her name is Victoria
Victoria thank you for writing Victoria
and I hope you figure out everything
that you want to figure out and you're
young and just [__] try [__] out and
it's okay to fail you're really young
yeah you're never GNA know what you want
to do until you try it I I think the wor
situation that you could be in is when
you're sitting here wondering what you
could have done but you never tried it
and then you have a hard stance on
something that do make sense you got to
pull the trigger like I know so many
people they go oh my God like like I
stand up doesn't make sense as a [__]
living like why would you ever do that
it's like well cuz you're not funny and
number two you would never be successful
in it don't [__] on other people's
that's someone else's job what you
talking about I think too for someone
that's 15 like your relationship with
failing matters a lot like uh you got to
be like obviously no one wants to fail
but it's inevitable you're going to fail
ESP when you try something new but you
have to accept that as just part of the
process and if that actually if you if
you embrace it you're like okay I'll try
a bunch of [__] out and that's how
you'll find what the [__] you really
want to do you know yeah man [__] well
guys'll fine you'll be fine that wraps
of this episode of the Jus brain podcast
I got to say thank that was a lovely you
wrote this out so well young lady like
you're going to be successful she's 15 I
would have never wrote this 15 you're
going to be fine Correct punctuation you
she's going to be a ceoo dude this is a
CEO you be you'll be
FY you are the first person that wrote a
letter to me that has bullet points wow
and paragraphs wow indentations and
you're telling me you're not smart
reference you reference your information
you're great she going to be a CEO 100%
if I wrote a letter to somebody who was
giving advice my letter would start hey
blood I [__] with you with an X with an
X with X International for x x going to
give it to you X going give it to you
the link attached to the video exactly
well guys you could find Patrick at
Patrick T.Y on Instagram remember when
stand up comes back your boy going to be
killing that stage BL BL blop SK W [__]
SK Bop and then Nick you can find Nick
in the garbage can outside of your home
EA your cookies
[__] your cookies and making that sweet
teast sweet come on baby but Nick the
ear at Instagram and everything else
Nick the.com you can hit him up for
personal training my man has helped
people lose weight but got me fatter by
the second come on baby everyone needs a
coach and everyone needs some help no
stop stop stop I didn't that was just
like I thought we're going to cut it
from therey w w see y'all next time